[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans politique
à table sur LCP on se retrouve autour
d'un plat d'un dessert d'un invité et
cette semaine nous recevons Pascal
Lavergne bonjour bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invité est avec
moi pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigit bonjour monsieur laavgne
bonjour Jean-Pierre vous êtes député
renaissance de Gonde depuis 2018 engagé
politiquement à gauche vous quittez le
PS pour la République en marche en 2017
pour suivre Emmanuel Macron ingénieur
agronome de profession vous avez
longtemps cultivé une double vie et oui
vous aimez les blondes les blondes
d'quitain au point d'en compter une
trentaine dans votre exploitation de
Saint-Sulpice de guilleurag dans l'entre
de mer exploitation que vous avez mis
aujourd'hui en fermage vous avez aussi
exploiter de la vigne toujours dans le
bord de lait et exercer le métier de
restaurateur de la fourche à la
fourchette vous êtes le témoin exigeant
de nos assiettes et au menu justement
une bonne viande un bon vin Jean-Pierre
exactement au menu du lourd un faux
filet sauce bordelaise donc au vin et en
dessert une tarte au citron mais
attention sans meringue dans le dessous
des plats on va se rapprocher de la
terre en vous faisant découvrir le
woofing une tendance qui fleurit un
petit peu partout dans le monde dans les
pieds dans plat le glyphosate c'est
reparti pour 10 ans en Europe faut-il
s'en
inquiéter allez on passe à table tout de
suite cuisine et
confidence alors Pascal Lavergne je dis
d'abord chapeau oser le faux fidèle à
bordelaise à cette table est un acte de
bravour culinaire de nos jours dans ce
climat de diabolisation de la viande
rouge ou même certains carnacier
Brigitte en a été témoin d'hier se
dégonfle aujourd'hui en arrivant ici
avouant leur conversion récente pour le
Kinois histoire de ne pas être charcuté
sur le billon des réseaux sociaux et oui
le faux filet l'entrecôte la côte de
bœuf sont devenus des gros mots pour
ceux qui veulent éradiquer la viande de
nos assiettes et par ricochet saperer
les élevages c'est-à-dire votre métier
vous qui engraisser il y a encore
quelques temps une centaine de bœufs
avec amour et passion vous qui passiez
dans la journée du fumier mouillé au
parquet ciré de l'Assemblée on compr
prend donc mieux pourquoi vous le député
paysan vous incarnez cette résistance
avec ce faux filet cuisiné avec du vin
vous êtes engagé volontaire dans ce
bataillon des cocardiers défenseurs de
nos terroirs un bon vin une bonne viande
un bon fromage on connaît la suite ce
n'est pas du Macron dans le texte mais
c'est du Roussell et ça pourrait être
carrément votre devise ben pourquoi pas
oui ben écoutez oui moi je n'ai pas du
tout hésité quand il s'est agit de
choisir un plat pour venir le déguster
en votre présence bon voilà j'assume
parfaitement le fait d'avoir été éleveur
d'avoir un pied encore sur une
exploitation agricole que j'ai mise en
fermage ça a été dit il y a il y a très
peu de temps je suis vraiment le
défenseur de de l'agriculture française
le défenseur d'une d'une façon de de
d'élever des animaux et je veux
réaffirmer ici au travers de ce plat
choisi de viande rouge que l'élevage
beauvin l'élevage en France euh apporte
beaucoup d'externalités positives à la
biodiversité quand il quand on élève en
fait les animaux sur des terroirs euh de
prairie pensons à toute cette zone du
Massif central à l'alliier au charolet
qui qui élève des animaux sur des tê sur
des prairirie voilà qui apporte beaucoup
beaucoup de de qualité à nos paysages
ces paysages encore beauc aujourd'hui
c'est c'est politiquement incorrect pr
manger de la viande fiche je m'en fiche
du politiquement correct et incorrect
vous savez j'ai été jeudi dernier à un
congrès sur l'agroécologie à Bordeaux il
devait y avoir à peu près 400 ou 450
personnes dans la salle je n'avais
jamais vu autant d'écolos en même temps
réunis dans même dans la même salle
autour d'intervenant et député
Renaissance présent et un moment un des
un des intervenants a dit oui il faut
manger moins de viande certes oui alors
j'ai repris un pe vous êtes
d'accordou on pe effectivement manger
moins de viande parce que pour la santé
c'est sans doute une bonne chose pour
l'équilibre planétaire c'est sans doute
également une bonne chose pour pouvoir
permettre de nourrir toutes les
populations sur tous les sur tous les
continents avoir un peu moins de
consommation d'une viande qui utilise
effectivement des céréales qui pourrait
être directement consommé par par par
les humains directement je le conçois il
y a pas de il y a pas de difficulté il y
a pas de difficulté par rapport à ça on
y reviendra sur ce sujet mais en
l'occurrence la viande telle qu'on l'a
produit en France certes si pour
l'engraisser il faut des céréales mais
on a aussi des élevages qui sont
naisseurs qui sont éleveur et tout ça ça
se fait sur des prairies et les prairies
je suis désolé on abordera ce sujet tout
à l'heure du glyphosate on n'utilise pas
de glyphosate sur les prairies et les
prairies elles apportent des
externalités positives pour conserver
l'eau dans le sol pour augmenter les
taux de matière organique des sols et
c'est hyper important pour pour
l'agriculture française vous trouvez
qu'on accompagne aujourd'hui assez bien
les agriculteurs les éleveurs justement
en disant bah il faut manger moins de
viande mais vous vous aviez vos blondes
d'quitain justement un chaptael d'une
trentaine à peu près de vaches de bœ
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'on
qu'on vous accompagne aujourd'hui suff
écoutez ce que je trouve c'est qu'il y a
un discours ambiant qui est délétaire
pour les agriculteurs à chaque fois que
on on voit comme ça a été le cas il y a
quelques mois repris dans dans la presse
par la presse sans doute de façon
maladroite le le rapport qui avait été
fait par par la Cour des comptes moi
j'ai fait des band de 1 km de haut enfin
j'ai dit c'est pas possible enfin quand
vous êtes agriculteur que vous lisez ce
que ce qu'on a lu de ce qu'il avait été
ressorti en fait de ce rapport c'est de
dire comment les agriculteurs pouvent le
lire en disant ben écoutez les gars vous
polluez ce que vous faites ce que vous
produisez il faut pas en manger parce
que c'est c'est c'est pas bon pour la
santé c'est pas bon pour l'environnement
et donc on leur dit ben vous servez à
rien et vous allez disparaître non mais
sincèrement quand vous êtes quand vous
avez fait de ce métier votre vie tout
entière que vous avez mis tout votre
cœur parce que on fait pas on fait pas
ce métier sans y être charnellement
attaché enfin à nos animaux à notre
terroir on fait ce métier par passion et
quand vous lisez ça ben excusez-moi mais
c'est c'est ça vous fend le C mais la
politique que vous menez vous parce que
vous avez ces deux casquettes
aujourd'hui la politique que vous menez
à Renaissance vous avez l'impression
qu'elle va dans le sens des éleveurs
écoutez moi je crois que en tout cas à
la place qui est la mienne je fais
passer des messages dans la majorité euh
tous les groupes de la majorité mais
également en direction de l'opposition
pour dire combien l'élevage il est
important comme je viens de le dire ici
sur ce plateau et si s'il y a un combat
que je mnerai jusqu'au dernier jour
jusqu'à mon dernier sou ça sera celui-ci
je ne suis pas fils d'agriculteur j'ai
choisi ce métier de depuis l'âge de 7
ans il se trouve que je suis passé par
par plusieurs étapes avant de devenir
agriculteur mais voilà je l'assume
jusqu'au bout et sincèrement jusqu'à mon
dernier soup je défendrai l'agriculture
et l'élevage et l'élevage français
sachant que j'ai conscience de tout cet
environnement négatif mais la nécessité
de de de dire combien les agriculteurs
ont fait d'efforts depuis des décenn que
moi je les observe presque 40 ans plus
de 40 ans de ma vie l'agriculture elle
se elle se rénove au rythme des saisons
au rythme du du du climat rythme du
climat et sincèrement voilà il faut faut
laisser le temps vous avez dit je suis
un ardent défenseur de la viande rouge
elle est dans votre assiette on on va la
goûter et dites-nous pourquoi vous avez
choisi ce plat parce que je crois que
c'est un plat symbolique des vendange
dans dans le bord de lait alors j'ai
choisi ce plat pour pour deux raisons un
parce que c'est de la viande rouge et
que je veux réhabiliter la viande rouge
vous l'avez
compris que j'ai été éleveur et j'ai
également comment fait des concours
cours autour de la race bazadz hein qui
est ah bah on regarde une photo ensemble
de cette fête des B grat beza les be
gras de Bazas
voilà la basadè c'est une race purement
girondine et voilà j'ai j'ai été un
petit peu identifié dans le milieu de
l'élevage au travers de cette race
basadz parce que j'ai eu la le plaisir
de faire des concours et de les gagner
ce qui m'a permis effectivement après de
faire du circuit court et d'avoir une
certaine renommée autour autour de la
viande la viande de qualité alors cette
sauce bordaise alors ça c'est du faux
filet parce que bon on av alors soyez
indulgent parce que nous on le fait
réchauffer c'est pas un restaurant ici
mais on sent que c'est de la bonne
viande et cette sauce bordelaise c'est
une sauce au vin alors c'est une sauce
au vin vin et échalote avec avec du fond
de veau donc c'est quelque chose qui a
beaucoup mettre bon vin ou il faut
mettre un non on peut mettre un vin un
vin de base c'est pas pas un problème le
vin le bon vin on le garde pour le BO
voilà mais l'idée c'est de le cuire
c'est de d'essayer de concentrer un
certain nombre d'arôme de les mélanger
avec avec l'échalot qui est quand même
assez relevé assez assez atypique et
voilà on on fait couler ça sur la viande
comme ça avec cette sauce là qui est un
peu épaisse d'ailleurs tout à fait alors
la typicité en fait de la consommation à
Bordeaux c'est des viandes épaisses hein
c'est pour ça que l'entrecôte bien
souvent c'est du 5 6 cm qu'on fait
revenir sur les sments sur les sments de
sur les sments de vigne juste avant le
repas pendant les vend c'est c'est
également le plat préféré des chasseurs
qui chassent la palombe et quasiment
tous les jours en fait dans les
palombières dans dans le sud-ouest dans
le sud girond on mange également
l'entrecôte de bœuf qu'on achète à
basass c'est plus gras que le faux
fidèle l'entrecôte c'est ça pour les
pour ceux qui nous écoute et mais bon
l'entrecôte le faux filet euh la
bassecôte tout ça c'est pris sur le dos
le dos de l'animal long de la colonne
vertébrale et donc vous avez d'abord au
plus près du collier c'estàd vous avez
les bass côtes c'est un petit peu plus
ferme ça dépend des animaux ensuite vous
avez l'entrecôte qui elle effectivement
est assez grasse peut être percillé ça a
des grands des grands morceaux de de
nerf pour séparer pour séparer les les
les les parties hein malgré tout de de
l'entrecôte et ensuite vous avez le faux
filet qui lui est un peu moins gras
qu'on qu'on retrouve vers la fin et
ensuite vous avez le romstrek qui est
encore moins gras et qui est comment
avec une fibre un petit peu plus serré
il y en a pour tous les goûts mais
sachant que à Bordeaux on m on mange
plutôt la viande bleue
assignant pour garder toute sa pourer
toute sa saveur toute euh bah tout son
jus bah trois choses à savoir alors
Jean-Pierre effectivement sur pour
réussir cette cuisson du faux filet
alors alors je m'adresse à tous ceux qui
cuisinent de la viande chez eux encore
le plus simple c'est le cuir à la poêle
hein commencez par l'assaisonner avec du
sel et du poivre préchauffer bien la
poêle avec huile ou beurre ça dépend des
goûts pour la cuisson alors comme vient
de le dire monsieur le député juste
saisi pour un faux filet bleu hein 3
minutes de chaque côté pour une pièce un
peu saignante et plus mais c'est un peu
souvent du gâi pour une viande à point
laissez bien la viande reposer un peu
dans du papier aluminium avant de la
déguster ça permet de de faire un peu
évacuer le le sang ensuite au barbecue
vous avez le choix alors grillé ou
mariné je sais pas si vous aimez la
viande marinée Brigitte là il y a toutes
sortes de marinade et là il faut
préparer son grill sur ce barbecue en
brossant un peu avec d'huile et là c'est
pareil on fait un clic clac comme ça de
à 3 minutes enfin cette viande tendre
elle adore aussi le four elle adore
aussi d'être roôti alors glissez-la au
four vous la saisissez d'abord avant de
la glisser sur la poêle vite fait un
aller-retour et ensuite 210 ça c'est 15
minutes et si vous le voulez moins un
peu plus cuit bien c'est 12 15 minutes
et puis vous baissez la température
entre 52 et 54 si vous rêvez de déguster
un rôti rosé c'est très bon aussi le
rôti rosé vous êtes d'accord avec moi
absolument d'accord juste une chose à
rajouter par rapport aux différentes
cuissons que vous avez décrit de façon
parfaite la viande on ne la cuit pas dès
qu'on quand on la sort du frigo on le
laisse déjà reposer 2 à 3 He notamment
quand on a des morce 3 He moi j'ai qu
d'heure ou mais par parce que bon ça
dépend comment régler votre frigo si
c'est un frigo on va dire de de cuisine
classique il est peut-être à 6 7 degrés
effectivement vous pouvez vous contenter
de ça mais si vous avez un bon frigo qui
marche où vous avez une viande qui est
entre 0 et 3°gr laissez lui le temps de
prendre la chaleur ambiante de la
cuisine de la pièce dans laquelle on va
la déguster
elle n'en sera que meilleure alors vous
vous avez été éleveur restaurateur mais
restaurateur ça veut pas dire cuisinier
est-ce que vous aimez être en cuisine
est-ce que vous savez cuisiner j'imagine
la viande vousz avoir plein de recettes
à nous à nous raconter euh que alors en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence je ne suis
pas cuisinier de formation je n'ai
jamais de fait de formation technique en
la matière euh j'occupais quand même une
place dans ENF j'ai fait tous les postes
dans mon dans mon établissement mais en
l'occurrence le poste que j'ai fait on
va dire le plus le plus longtemps c'est
celui de de cuire de cuire la viande à
la plancha donc c'est pas une cuisine on
va dire c'est assez facile he mais il
faut c'est assz facile mais enfin il
faut quand même quand même le
fairerectement rest
ououi c'est vrai que les pointilux votre
restaurant s'appelit la pièce de bœf he
ça s'app la pièce de BF voilà c'est ça
donc on dégusta essellement la VI a pas
de secret ce qui n' pas ce qui n'a pas
et avec avec effectivement ma viande oui
tout à fait un circuit très court
absolument c'est pour ça que votre
collègue a dit tout justement de la
fourche à la fourchette ça n'a pas
empêché malgré tout un certain nombre de
clients je me rappelle un dimanche soir
quelqu'un qui qui se pointe qui venait
de jouer de la musique et à 21h il
arrive en disant Pascal tu tu tu sais je
suis végétarien tu ne pourrais pas nous
faire des burgers végétariens je lui dis
mais tu as regardé l'enseigne ici ça
s'appelle la pièce de bœuf et puis
finalement je me suis ravisé je dis il
faut pas faut pas être caractériel comme
ça faut pas le prendre mal et je vais
m'efforcer de de lui faire un un
hamburger végétarien et finalement
c'était en été on a aussi beaucoup de
légumes dans le Sud-Ouest on a cette
chance-l il y a des tomates il y a des
herbes en tout genre et puis finalement
en prenant des des bonnes tomates cœur
de bœuf où il y a assez peu de pépin
beaucoup de cher vous vous la vous la
faites elle aussi cette tomate juste
snacké sur la plancha vous mettez
quelques herbes pour donner du goût de
l'ail vous mettez un œuf puisque le
végétariens mangent également de de de
l'œuf et ben vous vous pouvez arriver à
faire des magnifiques burgers et le gars
est revenu après en disant Pascal
sincèrement c'est le me meilleur burger
végétalien que je n'ai jamais mangé de
ma
vie un viandard c'est un exploit ben
écoutez oui mais comme quoi il faut
rester ouvert et j'aimerais que ceux qui
sont végétariens soient aussi ouverts
sur ceux qui mangent de la viande que
moi je l'ai été ce jour-là VO beaucoup
de respect sur sur les ou sur les autres
ça m'est arrivé également de débarrasser
les assiettes euh en salle et en fait
vous vous apercevez des fois en
débarrassant les assiettes que Ben le
morceau de viande il a complètement
disparu et puis il reste un petit peu de
légumes par-ci par là ou des fois voir
beaucoup beaucoup et je j'avais toujours
cette réflexion en disant mais
finalement les protéines adimbal ont bon
reste ça vous a choqué cette radicalité
quand on a vu des boucheries attaquer
oui bien sûr bien sûr c'est c'est
choquant parce que sincèrement s'en
prendre au bien s'ans prendre aux
personnes s pruttêre qu'ils ont une
orientation culinaire qui continuent à à
véhiculer une tradition bouchère c'est
des métiers difficiles c'est des métiers
extrêmement des mon père était bouché de
métier voilà donc je je connais
également ça sincèrement c'est jamais
agréable quand vous arrivez dans votre
entreprise et que vous voyez qu'on a
sali votre outil de travail pour
dénoncer ce que vous faites alors que
c'est ce que vous faites est légal et
sincèrement c'est très désagréable et je
comprends la colère des gens quand il
quand ils son sont victimes de ces de
ces menacesl euh qui sont véhiculés au
cœur de la nuit dans l'anonymat sous des
masques alors que eux travaillent de
façon ouverte généreuse et à visage
complètement découvert vous avez vu que
la dernière boucherie chevaline a fermé
ses portes est-ce que vous trouvez que
c'est une bonne
chose le cheval a une
connotation un petit peu particulière
moi je je je manger de la viande de
cheval deux trois fois peut-être dans ma
vie euh bon je préfère sincèrement la
viande de bœuf qui est beaucoup plus qui
est beaucoup plus grasse beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus goûteuse euh il y a une
proximité effectivement
affective avec avec avec les chevaux euh
que vous n'avez pas vous avec vos B pas
de la même façon c'est pas de la même
façon on les monte pas mais non parce
qu'on dit qu' vous aimez forcément vos
bêtes on peut pas faire dans la
sensiblerie vous savez c'est moi qui
amené mes animaux à l'abattoir avec mon
tracteur et ma bétaillère je préférais
d'ailleurs que ce soit moi qui le fasse
parce que on se cache pas derrière
quelqu'un euh pour aller accomplir un
acte qui est pas un acte très très
rigolo finalement que de que de tuer un
animal pour le manger mais depuis tout
gosse j'ai vécu sur une ferme et ben le
mercredi on tuit le lapin on tué le
poulet qu'on allait manger qu'on allait
manger au au au dîner au déjeuner ou ou
au dîner bah je sais ça ça on l'intègre
et puis on va pas en faire une
sensiblerie pour autant euh changer les
temps changer les gens ne veulent plus
qu'on tue des animaux comme ça pour se
nourrir écoutez certaines parties de la
population où effectivement on le voit
mais sincèrement j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a quand même encore pas mal de gens
qui mangent la viande au point que on
est obligé d'importer des viandes qu'on
ne produit pas en France parce que on a
tellement jeté le disc crrédit sur nos
agriculteurs que certains se découragent
on décapitalise beaucoup du du cheftel
français et c'est dramatique parce que
je voudrais réinsister sur ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure c'est toutes les
externalité positive quiapporte
l'élevage à la à la France et à ces
paysages mais également à la gestion de
la ressource en eau vous savez toutes
ces zones du Massif central qui sont en
zone herbagère qui servent de filtre à
l'eau qui servent de de réservve à l'eau
du fait de de de la présence d'un taux
de matière organique très élevé dans les
sols herbagés qui permet de stocker de
l'eau c'est extrêmement important alors
on va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable c'est le
quiz alors vous qui êtes le chantre
d'une viande de qualité vous ne pouvez
que détester le fameux spam ce cousin du
cornet beef sauriez-vous nous dire si
ses affirmations à son sujet donc au
sujet du spam sont vrai ou fausses le
spam est né en 1937 pour offrir une
conserve rassasiante et très bon marché
pendant la grande crise oui vrai voilà
exactement comme son cousin le cornet
beef le spam et de la viande de bœuf
cuite 3 heur dans une boîte en métal je
pense qu'il y a d'autres viandes que le
viande de bœuf exactement c'est pas du
tout du bœuf c'est de l'épaule de porur
bravo
pendant la guerre miale les amécains
dégoûtés par cette ration quotidienne le
surnomme le jambon de singe mort oui non
il il appelle le jambon recalé à
l'examen médical c'était à peu près
pareil ou le S Mor c'est c'est à moi
c'est une trouvaille son succès a
continué après la guerre en 2007 dernier
chiffre connu c'était vendu dans le
monde 1 milliard de boîtes de spam fa
vous diriez plus ou Mo non je moin non 7
milliards 7 milliards voà ouais c'est
peut-être pas bon mais il y en a un paet
qui en mange quand même les gens m et le
spam c'est devenu cette viande pourri
quand on a un mail pourri on l'appelle
le spam le spam effectivement dans ces
boîtes mail alors out on va garder notre
faux filet hein oui outre un gros
consommateur de viande que désigne aussi
le mot viandard un cheval diforme
oui ou non un cheval diforme oui oui le
M viandard c'est aussi un cheval diforme
un chasseur compulsif non oui si aussi
c'est aussi un viendard le chasseur
compulsif un homme qui ne réussit rien
un
loser est-ce que c'est est-ce que est-ce
que le mot viandard correspond à cette
pas dans mon esprit non non
effectivement et une grille pour faire
cuire la viande rouge non non plus
exactement 2 sur qu 50 % de réussite
alors avec une bande viande on on boit
un bon ou alors si possible si possible
et donc on a choisi enfin vous avez
choisi un Bordeaux un Bordeaux bordeau
supérieur c'est le château Fran couplet
c'est ça on est sur un millésime
2016 évidemment c'est un c'est un vin
rouge avec un saage à 65 % Merlot assez
typique de ce de ce Bordelet que que
vous connaissez bien pourquoi avoir
choisi ce alors il se trouve que j'ai
été comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure conseiller agricole également
avant d'être moi-même agriculteur que et
et j'ai eu l'occasion donc du coup
d'accompagner des des des des des jeunes
qui voulait se se diriger vers ben vers
la vers la viticulture et en
l'occurrence voilà bah vous savez j'en
ai installé enfin installé j'ai
accompagné pas mal de projets
d'installation il fallait en choisir un
c'était pas simple en l'occurrence voilà
j'ai pris celui que je connaissais
depuis le plus longtemps en l'occurrence
c'est le château d'un ami qui s'appelle
Éric mayau qui est installé sur la
commune de landerrois qui est tout à
fait à l'est de de de mon territoire à
l'est de de l'entre de mer euh et de et
de ma circonscription c'est quelqu'un
que je connais depuis
1987 voilà moi j'avais 20 ans lui en
avait 15 et quelques années après après
avoir fait euh des études en lycée
agricole euh on va dire de viticulture
onologie il a décidé de de s'installer
son père avait déjà une exploitation
mais qui portait le le le le raisin en
cave coopérative une grosse très belle
cave coopérative et lui euh à partir de
de
1995 s installé également mais a voulu
en 1998 voilà faire le virage et
lui-même lui-même vinifi on sent que ça
ça passe en barique he voilà tout à fait
et donc petit à petit donc il a agrandi
son exploitation avec son épouse qui a
qui l' qui l'a rejoint avec ses enfants
qui qui sont pas encore en âge de
s'installer mais qui qui ont qui ont
contribué en l'occurrence à la création
de cette cuvée parce que c'est les
premiers c'est c'est c'est les enfants
qui qui ont mis ce ce ver Bari en
premier sur la première année où ils ont
décidé de faire cette cette cette cuvée
et c'est vraiment euh un bordeau
supérieur qui est qui est digne d'un
d'un grand V d'un grand vin de Bordeaux
il y a beaucoup de variabilités
qualitative mais je voulais vraiment
montrer au travers de ce château comme
quoi ben des des gens qui sont installés
à titre à titre individuel ont fait de
gros investissements de gros efforts en
terme de vénification se sont fait
accompagner par par des zonologues ont
embrassé des des techniques et des
technolog
moderne comme le microbulage ou autres
et et ont passé leurs vins en barique et
font des vins qui sont tout à fait
remarquable dans une appellation assez
modeste qui pas forcément la plus
vendeuse justement à côté de de
saint-émilon Pom rol absolument qui
bénéficie pas de ce rant là mais on est
capable de faire des choses très bien et
sincèrement je suis grand plaisir de
vous le faire découvrir et c'est un très
bon accord effectivement avec j'ai une
question pour l'expert du vin Brigit
quand on non mais quand on a une viande
avec déjà une sauce au vin et qu'on doit
rajouter du vin est-ce qu'il y a des
précautions à prendre est-ce qu'il faut
que les de vins s'accordent est-ce qu'on
peut boire sur une sace bordel du vin
blanc comment on fait ah euh du vin
blanc j'aurais pas préconisé de vin
blanc là pour cette sauce bordelaess
mais en l'occurrence le le vin qui est
dans la sauce est est déjà très cuit
donc de toute façon il a perdu ce côté
alcoleux qu'on peut avoir et je crois
qu'un vin rouge effectivement est le
meilleur accord possible et un vin de
Bordeaux c'est une valeur très très sûre
en tout cas ça c'est sûr avec 65 % Merl
25 % cabernet sauignon cabernet franc
qui apporte aussi un petit peu de de
fraîcheur au Merlot c'est c'est un bon
choix merci félicitations et ça fera
plaisir au propriétair alors voilà alors
c'est souvent autour de la table vous
vous devez le savoir que que se raconte
les meilleures histoires que ce nous
parfois peut-être des deals politiques
en tout cas c'est la brve de
comptoir alors Pascal Lavergne on vous a
demandé de réfléchir à une anecdote
politique autour d'un repas est-ce que
il y a une petite histoire que vous
pouvez nous raconter alors une anecdote
politique que je peux raconter autour
d'un repas oui sans doute l'anecdote
politique qui est celle qui a sans doute
le plus le plus marqué ma vie politique
c'est quand le le un 18 un 17 ou un 18
octobre j'étais sur mon tracteur le
matin en train de soigner mes vaches
j'étais déjà MRE de mon village m'en
séigure et je reçois un coup de
téléphone allô c'est Pierre galbessierre
du pôle politique et parlementaire de
l'Élysée oui bonjour
euh c'est Monsieur Laverne il avait
l'air surpris
il me dit est-ce que vous savez qu'
qu'on vient de nommer madame Christelle
du boss au gouvernement j'ai dit non
écoutez vous vous vous me la prenez et
donc c'est à ce moment-là comme j'étais
suppléant de de Christian du Bos que
j'apprends que je deviens député en
soignant mes vaches donc ben là je vous
savez il y a une expression qui
s'appelle tombé de l'armoire et moi je
suis tombé du tracteur là pour le coup
vous avez arrêté le tracteur ah oui oui
oui tout à fait il a quand même fallu
continuer à à soigner les vaches mais en
tout cas dès ce moment-là en fait tout
un tas de coup de fil de journalistes et
puis d'amis qui regardaient qui
regardaient les les les J journau
télévisé ou qui qui écoutait la radio
ben apprenait la la nouvelle en même
temps que moi qui était le premier
concerné mais qui débarquait
complètement et vous étiez heureux de
pouir
poursuivre oui enfin évidemment mais
c'était pas forcément c'était pas
forcément prévu à ce moment-là c'estd
que vous pensez que suppléant vous
n'accéderiez jamais à l'ASSÉ nationouis
que vous savez dans ces nouveaux députés
de 2017 dont faisait partie christiel
duboss on savait pas qui pouvait être
prédestiné à rentrer au gouvernement et
sincèrement quand je me suis engagé
comme supplément auprès de chrisal Bos
ni elle ni moi n'avions imaginé que ça
puisse arriver donc moi j'étais là voilà
au cas où mais quand on a 42 ans en
l'occurrence Ctait l'âge de christial du
boss on pas j'avais pas envie de la voir
mourir et elle non plus en l'occurrence
elle est rentrée au gouvernement c'était
la deuxième alternative pour que je
puisse siéger c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis venu dans le mandat
précédent ici pendant 20 mois et une
fois que vous avez raccroché vous êes
dit mais bon sang comment je vais
pouvoir faire en même temps le travail
au champ et le ou pasoui oui
effectivement c'est c'est quelque chose
qui vous traverse esprit oui pas il y a
pas de doute je vais vous dire la
première chose qui m'a traversé l'esprit
c'est qu'est-ce que je vais faire de mes
chiennes j'ai deux chiennes une Labrador
et sa fille qui est croisé la labradore
est plus là
elle est décédée cette année mais je me
suis posé la question parce que je je
suis célibataire je vivais tout seul sur
ma ferme pas pour ça que j'étais coupé
du monde parce que avec le restaurant
l'activité de mer je voyais beaucoup de
monde mais je me suis dit mais qui bant
va pouvoir s'occuper de mes chiennes et
en l'occurrence pour les vaches c'était
pas un souci parce que je savais que je
pouvais embaucher tout ça ça va pas
ensemble il peuvent pas garder les les
chiens avec comabité bah c'està-dire que
les les vaches ben vous les soignez le
matin vous venez les surveiller une ou
deux fois par jour s'il y a des des
potentiels villages et ça suffit les
chiens vous savez ils ont besoin de ils
ont besoin d'affection ells étaient tout
le temps avec moi sur la ferme ça ça a
été ma première préoccupation euh mais
c'est quand même compliqué à gérer
effectivement d'être à la fois
parlementaire d'avoir une ferme et
d'avoir un restaurant il m'est arrivé
d'avoir des coups de fil à 9h30 du soir
euh alors que la nuit tombe et dire oh
dis donc pascal tu as tes tu as tes
vaches qui sont sur la route à tel
endroit ok ben vous avez intérêt à avoir
des bons copains qui habitent pas loin
et qui se mobilisent pour pouvoir vous
faire rentrer les vages dans les champs
et réparer la clôture et alors les
chiens ils sont allés où ah ben les
chiens ils sont restés à la maison j'ai
fait une châtière pour chiens pour
qu'ils puissent rentrer et sortir de la
maison et puis finalement petit à petit
elles se sont habitués à vivre avec un
petit peu plus d'autonomie mais avec
toujours beaucoup de plaisir de
retrouver leur patron le mercredi soir
le jeudi soir ou le vendredi soir alors
ça va peut-être vous faire plaisir ou
pas mais en tout cas sachez que les
Français se rapprochent de la terre pour
certains ça passe par le
et ça permet de découvrir d'autres
cuisines aussi c'est le dessous des
plats
ah Brigit le woofing derrière cet
anglicisme se cache une pratique en
plein essor un échange sans contrepartie
monétaire les autres des petites
exploitations agricoles souvent
familiales toujours Bio propose le git
et le couvert au bénévoles contre une
aide dans les champs auprès des bêtes ou
pour toute tâche agricole c'est un
reportage bucolique d'éè Bonduel et de
Philippe
lecro Manu est en reconversion
professionnelle elle veut se lancer dans
le
maréchage on va commencer avec les
tomates pomm de terre et framboises
ouais et quelques poireaux aussi
peut-être on peut les manger parce que
toi tu kiffes les poireaues moi j'aime
tout moi et dans la microoferme de Kate
elle est venue s'enrichir de nouvelles
techniques agricoles j'aime bien l'idée
d'aller expérimenter voir si vraiment
dans le quotidien concrètement le toutes
les tâches tout la diversité des tâches
qu'on peut faire me plais et c'est
quelque chose que j'ai envie de faire de
manière un peu plus durable comment
faire ces semis tout gérer son compost
il y a énormément de choses qu'on
apprend et c'est vraiment chouette c'est
très
riche Manu est une wofeuse le principe
est simple elle offre quelques heures de
travail à Kate agricultrice bio partage
les travaux de la ferme mais pas
seulement l'idée c'est avec leoofing
c'est que ça devient pas un salarié pour
moi le B c'était que il vivait avec nous
il partageent tous nos repas tout le
voilà les bons moments de la vie les
mauvais moment de la vie comme elle ce
sont souvent des jeunes de 18 à 35 ans
plutôt urbains qui s'essayille à ses
échanges plus de 2500 fermes toutes bio
sélectionné par l'association wo France
on a 2000 woofers qui sont devenus
paysans et paysannes et qui ont qui ont
vu en fait au-delà du texte auelà des
discours en fait ce qui fonctionne et ce
qui fonctionne pas en terme de modèle
agricole donc c'est aussi une manière un
peu de de de venir se confronter au
terrain et de parler de modèle
économique aussi parce que évidemment
c'est pas que juste faire pousser c'est
aussi comment on vend sa
production une forme de reconnexion à la
terre à son alimentation aussi des
principes c'est qu'on crée la belle
nourriture donc on va prendre de temps
de vraiment de faire des expériences de
faire des beaux plats de profiter de les
beles nutriments que aliments qu' on
produit non il une vraie notion de
partage aussi autour du repas puis les
discussions qui vont avec les en c'est
c'est vraiment riche et les découvertes
aussi culinaire à chaque fois ouis qui
vraiment par les wof vient avec leur on
avait des woof japonais qui en créent
les plats magnifiques mais donc ouais
c'est c'est vraiment une une découverte
dans les deux sens
alors cette Trô connexion à la terre ça
do ça doit vous faire plaisir ou vous
jugez que c'est un peu gadget et ça vous
agace gadget oui enfin j'ai qualifié ça
tout à l'heure un petit peu c'est du
boboisme enfin c'est très bien de
vouloir recoller à la nature mais
aujourd'hui enfin c'est pas la vraie la
vie d'une vraie ferme qui permet si ce
sont des exploitations un peu
famili exploit n pas dit que ce n'était
pas différment il travaillent
autrement vous disiez tout à l'heure
vous étiez indulgent et puis tolérant
d'accord mais il y a pas de problème
mais je veux également revenir à un
principe de réalité ce n'est pas avec
euh des fermes comme ça qu'il faudrait
quand même multiplier de façon très
importante qu'on permet euh d'arriver à
la souveraineté alimentaire aujourd'hui
avec un modèle productiviste mais
néanmoins respectueux de de
l'environnement respectueux de la
biodiversité et de plus en plus euh on a
du mal à être autonome en France en
terme de production de production
alimentaire sincèrement personne ne me
fera croire que c'est ce modèle là qu'il
faut multiplier demain sur le territoire
pour permettre d'arriver
à cette souveraineté alimentaire que
l'on a perdu en France néanmoins est-ce
que les deux modèles peuvent être
complémentaires mais tout à fait tout à
fait je crois qu'il faut effectivement
faire coexister ces deux modèles tout
simplement parce que on le voit bien
avec avec l'inflation qui qui qui qui
est réapparu dans notre pays depuis
depuis la guerre en Ukraine
que les Français ils consacr une
certaine part de leur de leur revenus et
de leur budget à l'alimentation et on
voit bien que finalement les Français se
sont les le consommateur s'est détourné
des produits bio qui sont souvent plus
chers parce que il requierre beaucoup
plus de main d'œuvre avec moins de moins
de rendement à l'hectare ou au mètre
carré quand il s'agit quand il s'agit de
fruits et légumes et finalement les gens
se sont détournés du bio pour pouvoir
continuer à manger on va dire à leur fin
et pour pouvoir équilibrer leur budget
tout simplement parce que ils ont été
obligés de consacrer plus de leur de
leur revenus à au logement plus de leur
revenus au à l'énergie et sans doute
beaucoup trop de leur revenus à ce que
j'ai donné tout à l'heure c'estàd mon
smartphone voilà donc à un moment donné
il faut aussi assumer ça le fait que
depuis 30 ou 40 ans on diminue la part
de notre de nos revenus la part de
l'alimentation dans nos dans qu'on
consacre à notre alimentation par
rapport à nos revenus donc n'allons pas
me faire croire que c'est en en ayant
que des produits plus chers qu'on va
pouvoir répondre à cette à C
productiviste je défends un modèle qui
soit à la fois productiviste respectueux
respectueux de l'environnement et qui va
toujours vers qui tire vers le haut le
respect de la
biodiversité utilisation moindre des des
phytosanitaires et tout ça c'est en
route les agriculteurs comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure dans un propos
introductif ils ont compris ce message
que leur envoie la société que leur
envoie les citoyens mais à un moment
donné il y a une forme de schizophrénie
entre le le le français citoyen et le
français consommateur le français
citoyen a des exigences euh en terme de
de de de normes de production en terme
de qualité de production en terme de
respect de l'environnement et quand il
est consommateur il veut veut un prix
bas et il regarde pas trop d'où ça vient
et et finalement on impose des normes à
nos producteurs qui conduisent à ce que
ça renchérit le le le le coût de
l'alimentation produite en France et
finalement le consommateur s'en détourne
et achète des produits moins chers qui
viennent euh qui viennent de pays
étrangers de continents extérieurs comme
le Brésil où on déforeste encore entre
200 et 400000 hactares par an non mais
sincèrement essayons de remettre les
choses à l'endroit si aujourd'hui dans
nos circonscriptions nous avons tous des
agriculteurs qui tourne les panneaux les
panneaux d'
vout on en parlera mais revenons au
woofing Brigitte parce que là vous avez
parlé des petites exploitations bio ça
vous dites c'est pas gérable ça va pas
pr non c'est pas gérable c'est pas ce
qui va nous permettre d'obtenir la
souveraineté ce qui est intéressant dans
le woofing aussi ce sont ces jeunes qui
vont qui font des reconversions qui
étaient dans des bureaux qui vont vers
la terre qui vont se reconnecter qui ont
envie de la travailler différemment avec
des des pratiques ancestrales ça ça
devrait vous plire pas l'air trèsoui non
mais bien sûr ça me PLA
mais on peut on peut pas empêcher les
gens de faire ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire a quand même vous qui êtes près de
la nature et PRS vous devriez vous en
réjouir on est d'accord mais ce qui la
mission première de l'agriculture c'est
de nourrir les gens en 1963
1962 quand quand les quand les lois
d'orientation ont sur l'agriculture ont
été faites c'était de de de de dire aux
agriculteurs produisez de façon
suffisante et massive pour qu'on puisse
nourrir à bas cou à bas prix la
population l'agriculture elle a répondu
à cette mission il faut qu'elle continue
àouvoir répondre sinon nous dépendrons
nous dépendrons de modèle agricole que
nous ne maîtrisons pas qui sont sur
d'autres continents et qui bien souvent
seront gérés par des des des dictatures
plutôt que d'être géré par des
démocraties comme la France entendu
est-ce que ce genre d'initiative peut
rapprocher l'urbain du rural l'urbain de
l'agriculteur on voit parfois qu'il y a
des R elle le rapproche sans tenir
compte elle le rapproche sans tenir
compte de ce principe de réalité que il
faut être capable de produire des
carottes à un certain prix pour qu'elle
soit compétitive il faut produire du
pouletocher de la terre pour comprendre
vos contraintes à vous alors il faut il
faut comprendre l'ensemble il faut
comprendre l'ensemble des contraintes
que les gens et c'est bien la vocation
de la loi d'orientation agricole que de
réouvrir les exploitations agricoles
mais je veux qu'on on réouvre les
exploitations agricoles mais les vraies
exploitations agricoles celles qui
aujourd'hui euh remplissent les rayons
des supermarchés dans lesquels se rue
estce que ça c'est pas l'agriculture
intensive
auquel intensive agriculture intensive
ça ne veut pas dire c'est agriculture
conventionnelle mais c'est pas un gros
mot aujourd'hui c'est répondre à à une
demande du marché qui est de produire
des carottes des pommes de la viande de
poulet de la viande de bœuf à un certain
prix et si on n'est pas capable de dans
un marché mondialisé de de de de
produire à ces conditionsl et ben
finalement nous serons sous le coup de
de dictature comme nous avons pu l'être
comme nous aurions pu l'être concernant
l'énergie et demain moi je ne veux pas
pour les Françaises et les Français que
leur alimentation dépendent de
dictateurs qui feront ce qu'il veut et
qui leur font manger ce qu'ils veulent
alors vous parlez de principe de réalité
il y a une réalité que vous visiblement
vous ne voulez pas voir c'est que ces
jeunes gens cette jeune génération elle
a pas la même idée de la souveraineté
alimentaire elle a pas même idée de la
production agricole est-ce que vous
pensez quand même que vous
pouvez vous être un peu d'accord avec
ces nouvelles techniques cette nouvelle
appréhension
ncent triter la terre différ deç éé trit
leurs aînés comme vous ces jeunes
agriculteurs ce qu'il veulent c'est bien
très bien moi je vais pas les empêcher
de le faire mais par contre ils vont
vite se rendre compte que la société
elle va leur demander de produire ce qui
ce qu'ils ont envie de manger et le prix
auquel ils ont envie de manger et le le
budget qu'ils ont envie de leur
consacrer donc laissons les choses se
développer les unes à côté des autres ne
privilégion pas un modèle sur l'autre
mais ne condamnons pas de grâce ne
condamnons pas le modèle qui depuis les
années 60 permet de vivre et a permis de
consacrer moins pour son alimentation
par rapport à ces à l'ensemble de ses
revenus et de pouvoir bénéficier d'une
part plus importante pour ses loisirs
d'une part plus importante pour son
habitation et d'une part plus importante
pour finalement sa qualité de vie et sa
et sa santé ne cassons pas non plus ce
modèle là parce que il est risqué je
veut aussi que chacun prenne conscience
de ce risque politique là de devoir
demain dépendre des autres dépendre des
autres dépendre d'autres grands
continents dépendre d'autres modes de de
de pouvoir politique pour pouvoir manger
à sa fin alors est-ce que pour avoir
cette souveraineté il faut du glyphosate
on va le voir le glyphosate vient d'être
conduit pour 10 ans dans l'Union
européenne classé cancérigène probable
par le Centre international de recherche
sur le cancer cette décision suscite la
controverse alors on en parle et on met
les pieds dans le
plat
le glyphosate a été réduit de plus de 25
% depuis l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron qui
en a fait un de ses combats la France
qui souhaiterait en sortir cherche des
alternatives alors si certains
parviennent à s'en passer et bien ce
n'est pas le cas de toutes les
exploitations reportage d'Arian mauisson
et d'Augustin
Arnal à l'approche des semis Sébastien
berger contrôle l'état de son champ il y
a quelques jours il a désherbé sa
parcelle en pulvérisant un produit
chimique puissant du
glyphosate sous 15 jours 3 semaines on
va commencer à avoir une plante qui
dessèche et on va obtenir ce genre de
chose une plante qui est qui a plus de
chlorophyle depuis 3 ans cet agriculteur
a divisé par de sa consommation de
glyphosate grâce au désherbage mécanique
un complément efficace mais impossible
selon lui de se priver totalement du
puissant herbicide on a des plantes
résistantes qui sont plantes invasive et
ces plantes là à part la molécule du
glyphosate pour la réguler aujourd'hui
j'ai rien d'autre Sébastien berger
répand 1 lre d'herbicide dilué par
hectare de culture donc là j'ai du mon
côté droit la fameuse molécule du
glyphosate malgré la dangerosité du
produit il continue d'utiliser la
molécule pour assurer ses récoltes faute
d'alternative efficace c'est pas parce
qu'on a employer une mollécule qu'on
l'emploiera demain et la preuve en est
c'est que nos pratiques vont ber des
pratiques plus vertueuse et j'en prends
pour exemple chez moi j'en consommais
800 l il y a quelques années aujourd'hui
j'en suis rendu à 400 sur ma ferme et
demain ça ira peut-être encore en
diminuant à quelques kilomètres de là
pendant 12 ans Damien savoyant a lui
aussi pulvérisé du glyphosate sur
séchamp en 2016 il a renoncé aux
produits chimiques et s'est converti à
l'agriculture biologique à présent il ne
compte que sur des outils mécaniques
pour déerber les repousses de tournesol
sont arraché et les quelques mauvaises
herbes qui qui sont présentes aussi dans
le champ qui sont également arraché un
procédé plus long et plus coûteux qui
l'amortit avec un prix de vente plus
élevé de sa production l'absence de
recours au glyphosate est avant tout un
moyen pour lui de protéger
l'environnement aujourd'hui il y a des
études qui le montrent on sait que ça
coûte moins cher d'aider l'agriculteur
que de dépolluer l'eau le glyphosate
demeure encore l'herbicide le plus
utilisé en France en 2021 près de 1800
tonnes ont été vendues sur le territoire
national un chiffre en légère baisse ces
dernières années vous avez exploité de
la vigne vous Pascal Laverne est-ce que
vous utilisiez du glyphosate ou est-ce
que vous avez réussi à vous en passer
j'ai utilisé du glyphosate c'est
compliqué dans la vigne de se passer du
glyphosate euh tout au moins tout au
moins sous le sous le rang de plus en
plus effectivement les viticulteur s'en
passe moi je j'ai fait partie de ceux
qui euh j'ai eu mes premières ven en
1997 ceux qui qui n'ont jamais travaillé
leur vigne qui ont laissé enherber euh
l'interrang euh bon déjà c'est déjà une
orientation néanmoins il y a la
nécessité de de désherber sous le rang
aujourd'hui il y a des matériels qui
permettent de tondre sous le rang qui
permettent éventuellement de
cavaillonner de décavaillonner de
travailler le sol ça a pas que des
effets positifs non plus hein mais
effectivement on peut dans certaines
condition s'ans passer pas toujours mais
je peux vous assurer que là aussi le le
monde agricole a beaucoup diminué
l'utilisation de de glyphosate il y a il
y a il y a pour autant il y a pour
autant à mon sens la nécessité de le de
de le maintenir pour pouvoir détruire
des adventistes qui prolifèrent et on a
pas d'autre solution pour ça mais est-ce
que vous pensez que la Commission
européenne a pris une bonne décision
elle l'a prise seule hein d'ailleurs ça
on par je pense que je pense que la
Commission le reconduire pour 10 ans
sans aucune restriction je pense que la
Commission européenne a fait une erreur
politique parce que ça ça remet en fait
en fait une une couche une couche de
volonté de combattre le le le le
glyphosate alors qu'il a toute son
utilité pour pour pour l'agriculture la
position française qui était une
position intermédiaire de donner une
durée supplémentaire de 5 ans pour
laisser le temps de trouver des
alternatives parce que il y a des
alternatives sans doute ell nécessit
également des investissements de la part
des agriculteurs mais pour faire des
investissement il faut également dégager
des marges il faut dégager des résultats
il faut avoir des technologies qui
soient qui soit vraiment avéré on a des
marges de progrès que la recherche nous
permettra de de faire vous par exemple
financièrement vous auriez pas pu le le
faire en l'occurrence moi financièrement
je suis hors course maintenant mais par
rapport au vignes c'est c'est finalement
c'est c'est pas c'est pas tellement là
qui est le c'est pas tellement là qui
est le problème mais c'est surtout dans
les dans les grandes cultures euh
maintenant on tolère beaucoup plus
facilement dans les vignes d'avoir de
l'herbe sous les pieds bah déjà parce
que bah le climat il a il a un petit peu
un petit peu évolué aussi même si ça ça
laisse des supports en fait pour pouvoir
véhiculer le le les sports de mou jusque
sur sur les feuilles hein puisque c'est
par c'est par ricocher avec avec des
gouttes d'eau que le le mil d'ou remonte
sur le feuillage on tolère de plus en
plusos on le vaporise pas comme
ça quand je parle des gout d'au des gout
d'eau en fait des goutes d'eau de pluie
hein qui véhicule le qui véhicule le
Milou mais bon le glyphosate en
viticulture on l'utilise à des doses
extrêmement faibles uniquement
uniquement sous le ramp alors que on
pouvait l'utiliser à une époque sur la
totalité sur la totalité de la surface
ça c'est c'est sincèrement en
viticulture c'est pas un problème dans
les grandes cultures on voit qu'il y a
des des méthodes culturales qui sont
plutôt euh comment positive comme comme
les les cultures de conservation qui
consistent à faire des rotations des
cultures avec avec plusieurs avec
plusieurs plantes mais qui
euh empêche enfin qui évite de
travailler le sol et notamment avec avec
en supprimant la la technique de labour
qui est néfaste en fait pour le taux de
matière organique qui est néfaste pour
plein de choses pour la minéralisation
également des la minéralisation
également des des des des des des
éléments des éléments qui qui qui
proviennent du sol et qui proviennent du
du sous-sol et euh on on met en place
ces cultures de conservation en laissant
pousser l'hiver des plantes et on les
détruit avec une petite dose de
glyphosate de 1 à 1,5 l par hectare ce
qui est extrêm en fait rendez-vous
compte que nous nous avons entre 20 et
30000 tonnes de terre par hectare de
terre arable euh 1 L à 1 L de l c'est
pas comme si on prenait donc vous vous
dites à faible dos c'est pas euh
cancérigène probable comme le dit le
Centre international de recherche sur le
cancer mais mais mais le le le cirque
euh euh le Centre International enfin
voilà de de recherche euh dit que le le
le glyphosate est cancérigène probable
et je ne je ne dis pas l'inverse mais en
l'occurrence c'est classé 1a comme comme
les charcuteries ou comme la viande
rouge qu'on a mangé tout à l'heure euh
est-ce que pour autant on interit les
charcuterie et la viande rouge c'est une
question c'est tout question
d'exposition et d' une question de dose
sincèrement ça fait 50 ans que le
glyphosate est est utilisé je je
j'écouté l'autre jour Patrick Cohen qui
qui réagissait dans un éito par rapport
par rapport à la réintroduction du
glyphosate sincèrement si vraiment il y
avait une toxicité très forte du
glyphosate ça se serurait je ne dis pas
qu'il y a pas des des expositions qui
peuvent effectivement générer des
cancersê pour la prre plus pas moins que
d'autres choses que tous les jours
auquel nous sommes exposés un jeune
garçon qui s'appelle Théo grat qui a été
reconnu en fait victime du glyphosate
parce que sa mère av été
exp mère av très difficile c'est très
difficile à chaque fois qu'on nous prend
des exemples comme ça parce a des études
qui disent tout le contraire moi j'ai
une question un peu plus sur est-ce que
cette décision de la Commission
européenne va pas pénaliser les
agriculteurs français parce que la
réglementation française est plus dure
et plus contraignante oui je crois
effectivement que c'est une c'est c'est
ce que j'ai dit dans mon propos tout à
l'heure c'est ça ça ça n'aide pas
l'agriculture française et ça remet en
fait le le glyphosate sur le devant de
la scène et ça rejette l' probe en fait
sur sur le monde agricole alors que le
monde agricole français a fait beaucoup
d'efforts et nous aurions souhaité je
crois que c'était la position je pas je
crois j'en suis certain CIT la position
de la France la position du ministre de
l'Agriculture Marc fenau qui était de
dire écoutez alignons-nous sur la
position française qui a permis de faire
diminuer l'usage du gxphosat de 27 % et
notamment parce que la la SNCF n'utilise
plus le glyphosate les communes
nutilisent plus de gphosate pour les
et et ils ont pu mettre envre ça
réservant le glyphosate dans des
conditions modérées pour l'agriculture
là où on n pas d'alternative et en
attendant de trouver des alternatives
dont je suis persuadé que la recherche
trouvera et le machinisme agricole
trouvera avec avant 10 an avant 10 ans
pour donner un petit coup de booster à
la recherche et au fabricants de
matériel agricole tout en laissant le
temps aux agriculteurs de pouvoir avoir
une capacité d'investissement nouvelle 5
ans c'était sans doute une bonne limite
quit à revoir après 5 ans 10ant d'un
coup finalement est-ce qu'on va faire
les efforts
n trouver des alternatives je trouve que
5 ans c'était le c'était le bon timing
c'est pour ça que moi j'étais aligné sur
la position française écoutez Ursula
vanerleyen en a décidé autrement je le
reg parce que il faut également montrer
quand on est respons sa politique que
même si euh on considère comme produit
il est pas euh aussi néfaste que
certains on ont voulu le dire que on
fait un pas aussi en direction des
populations qui nous le demandent c'est
extrêmement néc Jean-Pierre l'a dit une
restriction plus importante sur le
glyphosate ça crée une distorsion de
concurrence avec les autres pays de
l'Union européenne est-ce que du coup on
va pas réutiliser davantage de
glyphosate puisque c'est reconduit pour
savez les agriculteurs sont des gens
raisonnables sont des gens
intelligents les efforts qu'ils ont fait
euh les techniques qu'ils ont mis en
œuvre qui sont vertueuses ils
continueront à le faire et je sais
qu'ils ne reviendront pas en arrière et
la réglementation en arrière française
ne reviendra pas en arrière je regrette
que les autres n'ai pas voulu s'aligner
sur nous mais en tout cas je suis
content que ce glyphosate puisse
continuer à exister c'est dommage qu'il
n'ait pas pu continuer à exister dans
des conditions un petit peu plus
exligeantes euh partout dans le monde en
Europe et partout dans le monde je
préfère qu'on s'aligne vers le mieux 10
ans que de s'aligner vers le moins 10
ans alors ça c'est une décision de
l'Europe il y a des agriculteurs qui se
plaignent des des des des des normes
européennes qui entrave leur travail
aujourd'hui et alors ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est qu'ils ont mis leur panneaux à
l'envers vous nous en parliez tout à
l'heure parce qu'on marche sur la tête
alors j'ai aussi le panneau de bac
commmune qui est à l'envers j'ai vu ça
sur facebook tout à l'heure bon voilà
benif stop au norm euré manif non
j'étais là aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée pas
avec le manifestant mais on me l'a
envoyé sur facebook donc je l'ai vu
c'est pour dire quoi finalement ben
écoutez c'est pour dénoncer c'est c'est
pour dénoncer sans doute la
surtransposition qu'on a eu tendance à
faire beaucoup trop pendant pendant de
de longues années et pas forcément avec
avec les gouvernements d'Emmanuel Macron
quoi qu'il aurait pu y avoir une forme
de tentation moi je voudrais sincèrement
que bien bien redire l'utilité que ce
soit le politique et le politique seul
qui soit à la manœuvre pour pour les
décision euh parce que c'est lui qui
après est en première ligne pour pour
prendre des coups euh ou pour pour
justifier des décisions alors que
parfois elles sont prises on veut dire
par par des administrations qui
finalement ne sont pas ne sont pas
exposées il faut vraiment que ce soit le
politique qui soit au cœ vous êtes
solidaire vous de ces agriculteurs qui
retournent leur panneau
oui d'une certaine façon oui parce que
effectivement je comprends le ralbol du
monde du monde paysan euh je serais pas
allé manifester ni retourner des
panneaux moi-même mais bien sûr que je
le comprends et je suis je suis
solidaire parce qu'ils ont envie d'une
lisibilité pour les 5 à 10 ans à venir
ils veul veulent plus qu'il y ait de
surtransposition ils veulent plus voir
disparaître de produits sans alternative
et je ne peux que les comprendre
d'autant que nous ne sommes pas capable
de faire respecter pour le moment des
clauses miroires dans des des de de pays
comme le Brésil qui continue à
déforester 200 à 400000 hectares par an
de de forêt tropicale et on s'étonne
après que le climat change et on
voudrait dire à nos agriculteurs plterd
parce que sinon vous allez continuer à
dégrader le climat arrêtez il faut faire
porter les responsabilités à ceux qui
sont vraiment responsables allez on
passe au dessert tout le monde a fini
c'est le péché
mignon alors on passe au dessert mais
enfin pascalen il est déjà passé au
dessert il nous a pas attendu parce que
visiblement la tarte au citron il adore
alors une tarte au citron sans meringue
c'était votre choix une tarte de saison
aux agrumes qui porte mal son nom
puisqu'il n'a à proprement pas à parler
de fruits dans cette tarte c'est un
mélange assez riche euh constitué d'œuf
de sucre et de jus de citron voire de
zeste c'est une crème appelée chez les
Anglais lemon curd donc c'est assez
lourd on dit souvent une tarte au fruits
c'est léger non là la tarte au citron
elle est de saison parce que les agrumes
sont de saison en hiver mais vous avez
tenu à ce que cette tarte au citron que
vous adorez visiblement soit sans
meringue pourquoi vous trouvez que la
meringue tue le goût du citron alors
déjà moi ce que je vais chercher dans
une tarte au citron est-ce que je
recherche ben c'est le citron et c'est
l'acide donc en fait à partir du moment
où on rajoute dessus une meringue qui
est sucrée on va perdre en fait cette
cet équilibre qui tend vraiment vers
l'acide et et en fin de repas même si
j'aime bien les desserts je préfère
plutôt un dessert qui tend sur l'acide
qu'un dessert qui tend sur le sucre
d'accord et alors pourquoi la tte au
citron tout simpement
par elle est quand même sucrée mais en
terme de goût là c'est pour ça que
j'aiai goûté avant vous pour pouvoir en
parler en fait on a quand même bien on a
quand même bien l'acide qui domine qui
domine c'est ça qui vous plaît
finalement vous n'avez pas les d son
trop sucrés C c'est ce côté qui est qui
est un petit peu allez qui qui énerve un
petit peu les papilles qui énervve la
langue voil donc c'est surtout la tarte
au citron pas les tes au fruits trop
sucré qui vous plî non mais je peux mais
aujourd'hui j'ai choisi la tarte au
citron tout simplement parce que c'est
également un dessert que j'avais mis en
œuvre dans mon restaurant ou il faut on
a commencé par un certain nombre de
desserts il faut de temps en temps
renouveler et en l'occurrence comme
j'aimais bien la tarte au citron un jour
je me suis dit bon ben je vais me mettre
à enfer on va on va essayeré et donc oui
mais enfin pas pas pas de façon
extrêmement artisanale parce que vous
savez dans un restaurant on a aussi des
obligations en terme de en terme de
normes sanitaires utiliser des œufs
qu'on casse c'est un petit peu embêtant
donc en fait moi c'était relativement
simple c'était 1 L de 1 L de jus de
citron qu'on mélange avec ce qu'on
appelle de la crème à froid qui est un
mélange tout préparé mais extrêmement
stabilisé hein où il y a effectivement
de la farine déjà les œufs qui est
pasteurisé vous mélangez ça mais par
contre moi il a fallu que je trouve
vraiment le le le bon équilibre en fait
entre ce que j'aimais c'est-à-dire faire
ressortir cet acide et le fait que cette
ce ce mélange tout près en fait du du du
du du commerce qui permet au
restaurateur de travailler en toutes ses
sécurité sanitaire était quand même un
petit peu sucré donc il faut trouver cet
équilibre et ce que j'ai j'avais rajouté
qui n'est peut-être pas rajouté ici mais
c'est de la crème chantilly non sucré
voilà qui permet d'alléger de donner de
donner également ce ce côté un petit peu
gras ce qui peut être également
intéressant pour visuellement rappeler
le citron c'est tout simplement d'avoir
des des tranches de citron très fines
que l'on coupe que l'on fait l'on fait
bouill qu'on peut mettre aussi alors on
peut effectivement mettre du zeste de
citron vert dessus ça rappelle ça un
petit arôme sympathique mais on peut
pour le sur le plan visuel également
mettre cette petite rondelle de citron
qu'on fait soi-même confire dans du dans
dans dans du sucre sucre et de l'eau on
le fait confire dans sucre et de l'eau
et on la met sur le bord voilà pour
rappeler effectivement le fruit merci à
chez Françoise bien sûr qui nous a servi
ces bon petit PL comme d'habitude on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de politique à table sur
LCP